Вітаю! Я Ольга Дудар.
Я історик, вчителька і дослідниця.
Ми продовжуємо говорити
про період перебудови.
Але від політичних змін ми перейдемо
в соціально-економічну площину.
Під час нашої минулої зустрічі я
просила вас звернутися до усної історії:
спитати у ваших батьків, дідуся чи бабусі,
родичів, знайомих про перебудову.
І, оскільки я сумлінна
вчителька, я зробила теж саме.
Я спитала у своєї тітки:
що вона пам’ятає про часи приходу до
влади Горбачова, про проголошення гласності.
І, насправді, я дуже здивувалася,
коли вона мені відповіла,
що для неї епоха – це черги, це побутові
нюанси і, на жаль, Чорнобильська трагедія.
Тому наша тема буде цікава,
не без гумору (те, що стосується
соціально-побутового життя).
Але Чорнобильська трагедія – це насправді
дуже складна і надзвичайно трагічна тема.
Крім того, я просила вас звернути увагу
на ті фактори, які сприяли перебудові.
І я від себе теж приготувала
таку коротку відповідь.
Отже, що ж сприяло перебудові
на мою думку і на думку
дуже відомого історика
Олександра Дмитровича Бойка?
Увага на екран. Він говорить, що
це, найперше – Гельсінський процес
і міжнародна розрядка 1970-х років.
Люди почали більше
говорити про права людини,
про різні документи. Була надія, що
Радянський Союз змінить свою політику.
І оце таке очікування – воно,
насправді, в повітрі залишилося
і чимало громадян
Радянського Союзу вірили,
що врешті-решт права
людини будуть захищені краще.
Далі це – гасла Горбачова.
Як він себе поводив, як
він себе тримав з людьми,
про що він говорив – все це
вселяло громадянам надію,
що зміни дійсно розпочнуться
ось-ось і вони будуть масштабними.
Дисидентський рух.
Завдяки тим питанням,
які піднімалися в самвидаві,
я сподіваюся, ви пам’ятаєте,
що самвидав – це література,
яка друкувалася на машинці вдома
або переписувалася від руки
і поширювалася нелегально.
Отже, самвидав, історії про дисидентів,
таємні розмови десь на
кухні з критикою влади
– все теж формувало
підґрунтя для перебудови
і невдоволення життям.
Люди хотіли жити краще,
люди хотіли жити якісніше.
І все це дійсно створило ось
таку канву для позитивних змін.
Окрім того, давайте перевіримо,
зробимо ось таке невеличке опитування
– які терміни із тих, що
зараз ви побачите на екрані,
стосуються періоду перебудови?
Увага на екран.
Так, я сподіваюсь, що ви уважно
поставились до цього завдання
і відповіли правильно, що перебудови
стосуються такі поняття як “гласність”
– це політика поширення більш
правдивої інформації про історичне минуле,
про певних політичних діячів, про
процеси на теренах Радянського Союзу
від його заснування і до сьогодення.
“Нове мислення” – це політичний
курс на припинення протистояння,
на припинення процесів
холодної війни. І “плюралізм”.
Плюралізм – це коли дуже
багато думок є доступними.
В часи перебудови йдеться
про політичний плюралізм,
коли стає можливою опозиція,
коли можна було висловлювати
різні думки і критикувати владу.
І це навпаки – підтримувалося.
Отже, ці три терміни
характеризують перебудову.
І я сподіваюсь – ви запам’ятали, що
розпочались ці процеси у 1985 році.
А ми з вами приступаємо
до нового матеріалу.
Якщо Михайло Сергійович Горбачов
в політиці давав більш чіткі посили,
то в сфері економіки
виявилося складнувато.
Було проголошено курс на прискорення.
Влада обіцяла, що підприємства і організації
отримають більшу свободу економічну,
що буде децентралізоване управління,
буде запроваджено госпрозрахунок
і купа-купа-купа обіцянок,
які насправді мали покращити
повсякденне життя громадян.
Які мали зробити конкурентноспроможньою
продукцію радянських підприємств,
забезпечити широкий асортимент.
І все це покладали, звичайно
що, на плечі виробників.
Що ж відбулось в реальності?
Якщо ми звернемось до такого
дуже цікавого джерела як карикатури,
то подивіться, будь ласка.
Папери просто стосом,
величезними пакунками
летять на бідолашних управлінців.
Щербицький на одній із нарад
заявив, що з Москви
прийшло 666 000 документів.
І цей шквал просто змітав.
Замість полегшення, виявилося,
що прискорення вносить
погіршення і ускладнення.
І ще дуже важливий такий
момент в економічних реформах
– вони не могли тривати
окремо від змін у політиці.
Треба було зважитись на рішучі
кроки, але радянська влада розуміла,
що як тільки відпустяться
всі важелі комуністичної партії
і буде перехід до реальної демократії,
управляти державою так, як вони
звикли, буде абсолютно неприпустимо.
І тому, замість реальних ефективних дій,
з’являються, як на мене, такі
абсолютно невиважені програми.
Можливо, якщо ви дивилися радянські
фільми, ви пам’ятаєте оці моменти.
Перше, це боротьба з пиятством.
Насправді питання вживання алкоголю,
і я підтримую його, має бути свідомим.
І здоровий спосіб життя має
бути важливим для кожного.
В Радянському Союзі проблема
зловживання алкоголем стояла критично.
І Горбачов та його оточення вирішили
все це радикально вирішити одним махом.
І в 1985 році запровадили
антиалкогольну кампанію.
Було, насправді, дуже цікаво
спостерігати за співгромадянами,
а міліція не мала спокою.
В період цієї антиалкогольної кампанії,
уявіть собі, в населення вилучили
418 000 самогонних апаратів.
На жаль, це все мало
негативний економічний контекст
через те, що алкоголь давав
суттєві прибутки в бюджет.
І під шумок боротьби з алкоголізмом
винищили елітні виноградники
в Криму і на Закарпатті.
Таким чином, втрати від цієї
кампанії набагато перевищили
весь позитивний вплив,
який міг тільки бути.
З’явилась купа анекдотів, це
питання висміювали всі, хто тільки міг,
тому що, насправді – боротися із
вживанням алкоголю надмірним
треба було іншими шляхами:
просвітництвом, пропагандою,
заохоченням тверезого способу життя.
Ще один негативний нюанс,
який дуже ускладнював побутове
життя громадян Радянського Союзу
– це боротьба з нетрудовими доходами.
Почали жорсткими адміністративними
методами боротися з тими, хто надавав
приватні послуги нелегально:
хто шив одяг, ремонтував взуття,
хто виготовляв певні
речі, можливо – готував
кондитерські вироби вдома
і продавав їх бажаючим.
Так само міліція
переслідувала тих господинь,
які в себе на присадибній
ділянці вирощували овочі, зелень
чи продавали, наприклад,
інші продукти харчування.
Або, якщо ці люди збирали
гриби, ягоди, лікарські трави
– вони теж могли отримати
великі неприємності.
І виявилося, що вся ця боротьба,
вона просто – фасад. Вона не
має ніяких економічних наслідків.
І тому треба було змінювати.
Горбачов проголосив принцип трьох
“С”, які мали посилити самоуправління.
Крім того, держава виділяла великі
кошти на модернізацію устаткування.
І знову ж таки – парадокс:
оскільки великі гроші йшли за кордон
для того, щоб закупити нове обладнання,
ці самі кошти держава не
витрачала на товари продовольства,
якими забезпечувала певні
категорії, наприклад, військових,
на товари повсякденного вжитку
і перенаправляючи ці гроші,
держава звужувала внутрішній ринок.
І це все теж прискорювало
економічну кризу.
Ще хочу звернути вашу увагу
на дуже такий важливий момент
– це прийняття “Закону про кооперацію”.
Михайло Сергійович Горбачов
проголосив, що тепер в Радянському Союзі
люди можуть займатися підприємницькою
діяльністю, але обмежено і під контролем.
Податки на таку підприємницьку
діяльність були доволі високими,
іноді – це 65% від загального прибутку.
Але люди, які мали в собі
оці підприємницькі таланти
і ми згадували про них на
минулому нашому занятті,
коли я вам говорила про
оцю незаконну книготоргівлю
– насправді багато із співгромадян
займалися отакими додатковими справами,
які давали іноді суттєвий заробіток.
Хтось мав пасіку,
хтось, хто проживав у сільській
місцевості, вирощував яблука,
груші, огірки чи томати.
Ті, хто могли це трошки розширити,
їх називали кооператорами,
суттєво впливали на економічне життя.
В Радянській Україні того
часу в кооперації було задіяно
близько 700 000 осіб.
І це доволі суттєво.
Обіг коштів у цій сфері складав
5 мільярдів рублів і це теж –
надзвичайно потужна справа.
Високі податки, на жаль, це гальмували
і держава все рівно повного відкритого
доступу до кооперації не надала.
І зараз я хочу з вами поговорити про
такий дуже класний практичний момент.
От з чим у людей асоціюються
моменти загострення економічної кризи?
Я принесла ось такий додатковий
матеріал – це косметика.
І коли я читала матеріали інших істориків,
дослідників моди, в однієї колеги я
знайшла такий дуже цікавий факт.
Її мама, маючи залишки чотирьох помад,
почала хімічити – вона їх змішала, нагріла
і зробила нову помаду,
колір якої їй не сподобався.
І це не був хімічний експеримент.
Через те, що косметика коштувала дорого,
якісну косметику знайти було дуже важко.
Вона намагалась ось ці всі залишки просто
використати і таким чином зекономити.
Або ви можете побачити зображення
звичайного для нас з
вами предмету – це джинси.
Коли мода змінювалася,
люди дуже хотіли отримати
(і я це пам’ятаю, це вже
було після перебудови)
оці варені, російською мовою “варёнки”.
Купити їх було непросто, дорого
і треба було мати знайомства.
В хід ішли миючі засоби, металеві відра.
І люди реально хімічили,
причому могли отримати
абсолютно неочікуваний результат.
Оці всі експерименти показують одне –
забезпечити свої повсякденні
потреби було надзвичайно важко.
Історики моди говорять про те,
що люди, не маючи можливості
купувати розкішні речі або якісні речі,
або багато речей – користувалися
одним і тим самим одягом.
Наприклад, доньки і сини
носили піджаки батьків.
Я пам’ятаю, мої старші
подруги розповідали, коли
можна було в магазині купити
лише одного кольору лак для нігтів
і вони використовували різнокольорові
чорнила від кулькових ручок
для того, щоб створити якийсь інший колір.
Словом хитрощів і
лайфхаків було доволі багато.
Але причина таких дій одна –
товарів було мало, а попит зростав.
І всі оці економічні дії часів перебудови,
на жаль, лише поглибили економічну кризу,
тому що влада не наважувалася
робити радикальні кроки.
Робити такі економічні
реформи і політичні реформи –
це мало бути в дуеті,
в такій міцній зв’язці,
щоб дійсно проблеми Радянського
Союзу почали вирішуватися.
І тут відбулась подія, яка
змінила життя України назавжди.
Чи часто ми про це згадуємо?
Напевно що ні.
Чи говоримо ми про людей,
які віддали своє здоров’я і життя
для того, щоб зберегти наші життя?
Не так часто як хотілось би.
Через рік після оголошення
курсу перебудови
26 квітня 1986 року, в Україні,
неподалік від Києва, в Чорнобилі
сталась найбільша техногенна
катастрофа в історії людства.
Її наслідки ми з вами відчуваємо,
хочемо ми цього чи не хочемо, і дотепер.
І от події навколо Чорнобиля показали,
що всі гасла перебудови не дуже то і щирі.
Влада не оприлюднила
правдиву інформацію одразу.
Влада УРСР не відмінила
першотравневі демонстрації.
Я була дуже маленька,
але пам’ятаю цей день,
коли ми з мамою ходили в центр міста.
Я пам’ятаю штучні квіти в руках
у мами, багато людей, всі веселі.
А потім – мені не дозволяють
виходити з будинку.
Ще через кілька днів приїхав мій дідусь
і забрав мене до сучасного
російського міста Курськ.
І ціле літо я, мама і моя
молодша сестричка були там,
а мій батько залишився на Батьківщині.
І коли я говорю про ці події,
хоча напевно, порівняно з іншими
людьми моя сім’я постраждала менше,
у мене на очі навертаються сльози,
тому що держава залишила своїх
громадян фактично без захисту.
Якщо ми подивимось на втрати?
Втрати від Чорнобиля
тривають і до сих пір.
Я користуюсь матеріалами, які розміщені
в підручнику за авторства Власова.
Він говорить, що в Україні,
внаслідок Чорнобильської катастрофи
було забруднено понад
2 000 населених пунктів.
Уявіть собі – 2 000 населених пунктів,
де проживало 2 600 000
громадян - це дорослі, це діти.
Ця цифра надзвичайно трагічна.
Окрім того, втрати на ліквідацію.
На 2015 рік вони складали
179 мільярдів доларів.
І ці витрати будуть тривати і надалі.
Десятки тисяч людей пішли з життя
через те, що влада не продумала
всі дії, не було дієвого захисту.
Є купа нюансів, але наслідок один – це
трагедія як шрам на душах багатьох людей.
Проте нам з вами, окрім того,
що ми маємо пам’ятати дату,
окрім того, що ми
маємо пам’ятати дії влади,
бажано б пам’ятати дієво тих, хто
боровся з цією страшною трагедією.
Основна частина робіт
по ліквідації наслідків
була виконана доволі швидко,
протягом 1986-1987 років.
Майже 240 000 людей
брали участь у цій роботі.
Крім чоловіків, туди залучалося і жіноцтво
– це ті, хто готували їжу, ті,
хто виміряли опромінення.
І це було, насправді,
надзвичайно небезпечно.
Наприкінці 1986 року
будують перший саркофаг.
Тобто було створено проект –
накрити спеціальним покриттям
4 блок для того, щоб стримувати процеси
і контролювати їх наскільки це можливо.
Я думаю, ви знаєте, що ці
процеси тривали і нещодавно.
В той момент над першим саркофагом працювало
дуже багато людей, і не тільки з України.
Спеціалісти, військові з
усього Радянського Союзу
працювали над тим, щоб,
як це не парадоксально звучить,
боротися з наслідками мирного атому.
Зупинити ось ці всі процеси,
мінімізувати ризики і наслідки вдалося
ціною життя, ціною здоров’я і
масового опромінення тисяч ліквідаторів.
Тому, на мою думку, ми маємо
пам’ятати про подвиг цих людей.
І для мене, особисто для
мене, історія перебудови – це
не зміни, не гласність, не економічні
реформи, а це – трагедія Чорнобиля.
Але у вас, можливо,
складеться трішки інша думка.
І тому я хочу закликати вас до ось такого
завдання, щоб ви попрацювали з матеріалами.
Знайдіть, будь ласка,
свідчення ліквідаторів.
Якщо для вас це складно –
насправді є дуже багато джерел,
можливо ви дивились
фільми, присвячені цій трагедії.
І ви зможете порівняти опис у
художньому фільмі чи в серіалі
з текстом підручника,
або з моєю розповіддю.
Це теж дуже важливо.
Крім того, ви можете
виконати тематичні тести.
Якщо ви вирішили складати Зовнішнє
Незалежне Оцінювання з історії,
якраз тематика соціально-економічного
розвитку через карикатури,
через характеристику процесів
– це основна тематика питань
ЗНО з історії України в минулі роки.
Є багато ресурсів, де ці
питання є у відкритому доступі.
Тому ви можете їх пропрацювати, виконати
і зрозуміти – чи матеріал для вас легкий,
чи щось потребує уточнення і
додаткової роботи з підручником.
Крім того, є тести, які автори
розміщують у вільному доступі
і є абсолютно велика
кількість практичних вправ,
які ви зможете використати
і зробити в інтернеті.
І якщо оці завдання для вас
не складні, якщо ви, наприклад,
легко вирішуєте тести – це означає, що і я
з вами сьогодні попрацювала продуктивно
і наголосила на оцих найважливіших точках
соціально-економічного
життя УРСР під час перебудови.
Я чую, що дзвенить дзвоник.
Я дякую вам за активність
і до нової зустрічі!